karl lauterbach und uwe jürgens hat sich
in den vergangenen monaten viel mit
carlotta mit wechselnden ergebnissen
muss ich sagen aber im moment ist mein
ergebnis sehr schlecht ich glaube karl
lauterbach erholt sich in meinem ansehen
nicht mehr ich finde wir müssen uns
intensiv beschäftigen mit der frage der
das des status der
genesenen
deren dauer auf drei monate verkürzt
worden ist von sechs monaten halbiert
worden ist ich glaube die diskussion
geht darüber öffentlich geführt worden
ist es immer noch nicht am richtigen
punkt und es wird zeit das zu tun das
will ich mal versuchen diese
überfallartige entscheidung hat schweren
schaden verursacht und zwar
auch für den bundestag im übrigen der
jetzt aufgefordert wird das
nachzuvollziehen was für die genesenen
in der bevölkerung verhängt worden ist
nämlich von sechs auf drei monate zu
verkürzen es noch nicht passiert der
bundestag hinter hinterher und das
bekommt sein ansehen nicht aber zunächst
mal geht es um die genesene die
genesenen sind von einem tag auf den
anderen aus ihrem leben rausgeworfen
worden denn sie können nicht mehr
irgendwo einfach in ein restaurant gehen
in einem café in ein sportclub in ein
geschäft in ein fußballstadion in ein
kino alles unmöglich geworden von einem
tag auf den anderen und die sind wenn
man so will inzwischen genauso verfilmt
wie die ungeimpften zu denen sind sie in
die ecke geschoben worden und das von
einem staat der so
obrigkeitsstaatlich kalt daherkommt und
es ihnen nicht mal richtig erklärt
sondern sie sehen vor den latz knallt
und wenn man sich die erklärung durch
liest die dazu veröffentlicht worden ist
dann muss ich sagen das liest sich wie
eine technische anleitung zum gebrauch
von spezialschrauben ja das ist nicht
besser es geht aber ums leben von
millionen menschen
und nun haben wir ja gelernt in den
letzten monaten dass die parlamente
wieder entscheiden sollen was der korona
politik passiert das ist aber in diesem
fall gar nicht so sein im gegenteil nun
sind die parlamente und die
parlamentarier selbst zu opfern der
korona politik geworden denn die müssen
sich gegen den eindruck zur wehr setzen
sie hätten sich ein sonderrecht
verschafft weil bei denen gilt noch
sechs monate die haben sich aber gar
kein sonderrecht verschaffte gilt das
weiter was bisher gegolten hat zunächst
mal und die sind überfahren worden wie
alle anderen auch also stehen an der
wand und überlegen sich was sie jetzt
tun sollen und sie sind nicht überfahren
worden vom robert-koch-institut was so
gemeinhin behauptet wird auch von herrn
lauterbach sie sind von herrn lauterbach
überfahren worden das robert koch
institut sagt ja selbst das ministerium
das gesundheitsministerium sei
einbezogen gewesen in die geschichte das
ist noch eine sehr harmlose formulierung
ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass karl
lauterbach das
losgetreten hat dass er das wollte denn
er
will dafür sorgen dass die
genesenen das sind im moment sind
ungefähr 1,6 1,7 millionen infizierte
werden alle mal zu genesen dass die zur
impfung gezwungen werden wenn er das mit
offenem visier auf der politischen bühne
versucht hätte in berlin wer in der
koalition da bin ich sicher gescheitert
und zwar in der fdp und spätestens in
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz jede
woche später getan das wäre also sinnlos
gewesen was macht er also er macht ein 1
1 ein ausweichmanöver
er macht die politische frage zur
wissenschaftlichen und schickt das
archiv wenn wir das ist schuldige das
muss ich noch zu ende bringen sind ein
paar wichtige sense das ist aber sie
haben nicht mehr so viel soja das ist
das muss man schon nehmen das ist das
hier das erste böse foul innerhalb
dieser koalition das erste böse von
normalerweise wird bei seiner
blutgrätsche eine karte gezogen auf dem
fußballplatz das ist gelb oder rot und
das müsste eigentlich jetzt olaf scholz
tun aber uns bleibt die frage ob die
politik nicht jetzt veranlasst es diesen
irrsinn zurückzudrehen also wieder zu
sechs monaten zu kommen für alle die das
die eu kommission für ganz europa
vorschlägt und wie es inzwischen auch
markus söder gefordert hat müsste dann
nicht fragt man sich müsste dann nicht
karl lauterbach zurückgetreten dann frei
die ich inzwischen der dass ein schaden
ich glaube nicht wolfgang kubicki wie
sehr viel gefoult sie haben ja auch eine
kleine geschichte mit karl lauterbach
gab es mal einen kleinen streit um ein
paar äußerungen und dann habe ich aber
wieder vertragen jain sie auch das geld
hat ja ja die wir pflegen tatsächlich
eine sehr gerne sehr
respektvolle der diskussionskultur
untereinander ich will auch sagen karl
lauterbach ist keiner der willkürliche
maßnahmen zwerg setzt um um uns zu
ärgern sondern den treibt einfach die
sorge um dass er überrannt werden könnte
von der krone entwicklung und er geht
jetzt nicht nur als der den talkshows
aufgetreten ist und als der macher aber
in der tat ist es so dass niemand davon
unterrichtet war und bin ich gewusst
hätte zwei donnerstagabend als wir die
die verordnung geändert wenn ich gewusst
hätte dass wir es dem rk überlassen
massive grundrechtseingriffe schlicht
und ergreifend durch eine mitteilung auf
einer webseite ins werk zu setzen hätte
ich dem gesetz nicht zugestimmt wie
viele andere dings augen so was machen
die da ist das mahlen die mühlen des
politbetriebs wie kann so etwas
passieren ja wie kann so etwas passieren
indem also
unterstellen ist gab schon
donnerstagabend absicht das freitagabend
zum lachen der bundesrat am freitag noch
zu bestimmen denen ist es auch nicht
mitgeteilt worden ich kann mich nur an
der salopp gesagt hat wir fühlen uns
alle getäuscht es wurde lange reden
gehalten und die notwendigkeit dass die
wissenschaft künftig entscheiden soll
und nicht mehr die politik ja ist ja
geil dass ich war noch dabei also auch
die union hat ja hat ja dafür gestimmt
und ich dagegen gestimmt warum weil die
verordnung nicht für die verkürzung des
genießen den status der schlimmste war
ja nicht der ist die konsequente folge
war ja dass wir als ärger in die lage
versetzt haben schlicht und ergreifend
durch normale verlautbarung eine solche
maßnahme zu machen aber so diesen
kommunikation wenn das der jens spahn
gemacht hätte da wäre hier aber da wäre
himmel und hölle hätten also der
eintritt meinung von new york ist ich
finde ich zumindest die kommunikation
ist eine katastrophe auch auf dem die
tatsache selbst schon eine katastrophe
wir hatten weil die sache zum einen aber
hat mich auch ärgert als
bundestagsabgeordneter ist dass sich
alle hinstellen und sagen die debatte
über die korona politik soll nicht in
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz geführt
werden sondern in den bundestag also
unbedingt kann ich sagen ja aber man
muss ja mal sagen der ministerpräsident
eine rente ja immerhin noch mal mehr
gewesen als irgendwie hinterzimmer des
ärgers die ministerpräsidenten und die
bundestagsabgeordneten erfahren dass
alles aus der presse aber da finde ich
schon da dem
100 sachen das ist der betrag sei das
halte ich für neben gleicher ich finde
daher schon gravierend da haben dass
verschiedene der politik gern es geht um
die substanz
ihr glaubt doch wohl nicht im ernst dass
eine nachgeordnete behörde eine
entscheidung von solcher tragweite
selbst trifft die millionen von
genesenen in die ecke stellt niemals das
hat die geschäftsgrundlage verändert
werden
damit haben wir alle lenherr vilas
denken würde hätte er natürlich immer im
ministerium nachgefragt und kein
staatssekretär traut sich das zu
entscheiden der geht zum minister und
der minister war in diesem fall da bin
ich mir sicher weil das war so ein
gravierender einschnitt würde akt macht
das uni halle mit merkel damit dass nun
haben wir unsere zeit stolz zu sagen hat
und dass er lauterbach taliban sind auch
der wein hat erklärt er wusste es nicht
hier damit dass eine solche würde
erhöhen werde sagte weise ja ich glaube
inzwischen dass karl lauterbach ist mit
der wahrheit nicht immer genau nimmt und
in diesem fall auch nicht er bestreitet
dass er das war und ich glaube er war es
ich glaube ihm das nicht mehr und ich
würde da ich glaub mir kommen das sagt
ja wirklich nicht weiter wenn er
wechselweise hersteller wollen ich will
ich nur noch einmal unterschätzt werden
das aufklären wir haben zu dem thema
eine kleine anfrage er dem blatt das ist
halt auch aufgabe der opposition jetzt
aber hier nicht so ich gehe nicht in der
hier genau richtig fried horizontal
wissen und der demo da wir zwei menschen
aus der politik hier haben und zwar
keine unbedeutende mich interessiert die
frage ob sie beide dafür sind dass diese
entscheidung rückgängig gemacht wird und
das ist wieder auf sechs monate geht
dann möchte ich gerne klare aussage
haben und zwar bundestag wie für die
bevölkerung mobilisieren für mich für
mich ja ich habe schon gesagt es ist für
mich völlig unverständlich wie die
bundesregierung auf der einen seite
durchs gesundheitsministerium den
genesenen status bei uns auf drei monate
reduzieren kann und die auf eu ebene mit
zustimmung der bundesregierung die
agenda ist bei sechs monaten verbleibt
die schweizer sind ja schon bei zwölf
monaten ja übrigens auch mit
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen war
keine politische entscheidung sondern es
stand im raum dass vielleicht sogar auf
ein jahr auszudehnen man sich darauf
geeinigt dass bei sechs monaten zu
belassen ist ja schon so und ich finde
es ziemlich komisch dass ich jetzt als
deutscher mit meinem genesenen status in
die in der spanien fallen kann aber mit
dem gleichen status nicht zurückkommen
können wie macht man denn das jetzt
politisch weit wer leider nicht ganz
zurückzunehmen philipp am tor hat sich
noch nicht an die oppositionsrolle
gebracht doch noch egal war neulich grad
sagen für opposition ist doch ganz
einfach
wir werden jedenfalls erstens opposition
heißt nicht einfach nur draufzuhauen
nachdenken machen war es auch in einer
kleinen anfrage wenn man es auf arbeiten
in einer sache finde ich es spricht
wenig dafür dass wir in europa eine
sonderrolle spielen bei dem thema ich
finde wir müssen jetzt im ersten schritt
erst mal korrigieren dass bundestag und
die normalbevölkerung da an der stelle
angeglichen werden dass eine echte
sauerei regen sich die leute zu recht
darüber auf und ich finde wir müssten ja
dann auch darüber in einem blog noch
einmal da ist ich bin ja auch vize des
bundestag noch einmal der bundestag hält
sich an die korona regel des landes
berlin und dem land berlin geht nach wie
vor in der korona verordnung der
genesende status sechs monate nach wie
vor hin des rates kennen ja die fälle
aus der eigenen fraktion habe ich einen
kollegen der mit johnson johnson geimpft
ist und dann diese konstellation erlebt
dass der dann jetzt noch einen
schnelltest machen muss vor dem
ausschuss anders als alle anderen das
ist auch okay ich meine der der
lamentierte auch nicht drüber aber das
ist natürlich eine situation die viele
bürger im land so recht irgendwie ärgert
dass ich da von null auf gleich der
status ändert also genau wohin sich auf
6 ja ich glaube dafür spricht einiges
die diskussion aufzufangen das
europaweit einheitlich zu regeln weil
genau der beschriebene fall warum soll
irgendwo in spanien der genesenden
status länger anhalten als in
deutschland maria fekter von der kollege
also herr wetzel der schöne immunologen
in deutschland hat gerade erklärt ist
macht immunologisch gar keinen sinn eine
unterscheidung zu treffen zwischen den
chinesen und ihnen die impften und dass
man auch mit doppelt impfungen booster
infektionszahlen kann das hat ricarda
lang gerade dokumentiert die gestern im
bundestag eine rede gehalten hat
unwissend dass sie infiziert ist aber
gewusst seine frau die
grünen-vorsitzende werden will er das
ist kann man ihr erklärt dass kein das
kann man ja nicht vor bergen aber dafür
nicht erst die runde wissen infiziert
war und dann für die impfpflicht
angetreten ist heute erkennen muss dass
ihr diese impfpflicht gar nicht
weiterhelfen würde was er ebenfalls als
gebucht hatte jetzt in 16 nicht
bestätigen auch doppelt kamen gestern
noch immer einen politischen gedanken
wir müssen uns daran gewöhnen auch nach
zwei jahren corona wieder politisch zu
denken ja und das naheliegende zu
erkennen stellen wir uns mal vorher
wiler hätte das selbstherrlich verkündet
der minister war ist es nicht und und
der bundeskanzler stellt gibt ja noch
die möglichkeit ist wurde an das
gesundheitsministerium weitergegeben und
dort nicht anhören lauter dann haben wir
drei
paar schuhe und eine staatssekretärin
dann sind doch mindestens einer von den
dreien ist verlässt ihn das wenn nicht
sogar alle drei falls ihr einen mussten
ist nicht der als selbstherrlich
entschieden und hätte es klare klar vorn
von unterwasser zurücktreten finden auch
nein noch nicht also immer noch
einige fragen zu ihrer gelogen selbst
herstellen er gelogen hat müssen wir das
weiter aufarbeiten und ich von dir
herzlich und ernähre sehr stark so ist
das wenn der in berlin die
ministerpräsidenten hinters licht
geführt und uns auch ja was ich nicht
glaube also noch einmal wir alle bei
aller distanz über eine sensibel wieder
haben karl lauterbach ist keiner der der
bösartig auf die ubs ist vielleicht
etwas überarbeitet
das ist der expertenrat beziehungsweise
die tatsache dass man von dem nicht mehr
so viel gehört hat